my name is dr. Evan I'm head of health
care in the Galman kisi group in in
Norway so I would like to talk about
people public-private partnerships and
how they can help us improve innovation
in Europe and to be more specific I have
an example of how we have created this
element in Norway in Denmark and what
we've been trying to do is to build a
biotech cluster focusing on cancer in in
our way and having a clear purpose of
what the cluster is supposed to you
bringing academics biotech and pharma
together to collaborate with the purpose
of accelerating innovation creating new
cancer medication and also to use a
Danish example from Copenhagen and
maluma they've come together in creative
medic in valley and now one out of 10 of
the jobs in the copenhagen area is in
the biotech field so i think this is a
good learning for other areas of Europe
and Central Asia find out what's your
strength of in your research where can
you have business collaborate with
academics and have business try to help
in universities in academics to to
transform their ideas into new new new
products the last thing is people you
need to have good people in good talent
and young talent coming in and choosing
to work in these high-tech industries so
if you don't have can attract the best
talent to your clusters you don't
succeed thank you